Today we're excited to share one of the first episodes of our new podcast, My Unsung Hero. There are several other episodes that you can also hear right now in the feed for that show, so please head on over to listen and subscribe. I'm Shankar Vedantam and from Hidden Brain Media, this is My Unsung Hero. Hey, I wanted to share my story about an unsung hero. Hi, Shankar. I would like to talk about my hero. My unsung hero is the man in the Panama hat on the flight to Boston.
今天我们很高兴分享我们新播客《我心中的无名英雄》的首批节目之一。您现在也可以在该节目的订阅源中收听其他几集，请前往收听并订阅。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆（Shankar Vedantam），来自隐藏的大脑传媒（Hidden Brain Media），这里是《我心中的无名英雄》。嘿，我想分享一个关于无名英雄的故事。嗨，尚卡尔。我想谈谈我的英雄。我心中的无名英雄是飞往波士顿的航班上戴巴拿马帽的那位男士。
As the plane nearer. My unsung hero would definitely have to be my fifth grade teacher, Mrs. Abrams. She was trying to teach me. I don't know who they were. I can't even remember their face, but I do remember what they did for me. I can't even express to you how much you've changed my life. Thank you. Thanks.
当飞机临近时。我心中的无名英雄绝对必须是我的五年级老师阿布拉姆斯夫人。她当时在试图教我。我不知道他们是谁。我甚至记不清他们的脸，但我确实记得他们为我所做的事。我甚至无法向你表达你如何改变了我的生活。谢谢。谢谢。
Thank you for making me feel heard. Today's story comes from Jackie Breaks. And as she gently touched my arm, she said, really, don't wait. [♪ Music playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing Briggs's life came on a Saturday afternoon in August 2006. I was attending what was built as a woman's health conference. Turned out it was really a pitch for cosmetic surgery, which really irritated me. But anyway, at that point in my life, I was 52 years old. And for several years, I'd been working 60 hour work weeks in this high pressure I teach job.
谢谢你让我觉得自己被倾听了。今天的节目来自杰基·布里格斯（Jackie Briggs）。当她温柔地触碰我的手臂时，她说，真的，不要等待。[♪ 背景音乐播放中...]布里格斯的生活转折发生在2006年8月的一个星期六下午。我当时在参加一个宣称为女性健康会议的活动。结果发现这实际上是一场推销整容手术的活动，这让我真的很恼火。但无论如何，在我他人生的那个阶段，我52岁了。几年来，我一直在这份高压的IT工作中每周工作60个小时。
And I had very little time for myself. So I really wanted to go and hear this one particular speaker. As a few hundred women milled around different booths, picking up brochures and eating cruditeys, offered by those black, panted, white, shirted, weight staff, this lovely, dark-haired woman came up to me and she said, shirted, weight staff. This lovely, dark-haired woman came up to me and she said, excuse me, but I can't help but notice your arm. I had what my boss later described
我留给自己的时间很少。所以我真的很想去听这位特定的演讲者。正当几百名女性在各个展位闲逛、拿取宣传册并吃着身穿黑裤白衬衫的服务员提供的蔬菜拼盘时，这位可爱、黑发的女士向我走来，她说，服务员。这位可爱、黑发的女士向我走来，她说，打扰一下，我忍不住注意到你的手臂。我有着后来我老板描述的
as what he thought was a rose tattoo. It was on my upper right bicep. And I was uncharacteristically wearing a sleeveless dress that day. Well, this woman who I have come to refer to as Angela, although I really don't know if that's how she introduced herself, or if that's the name I have since given her, but she asked me if I'd seen a dermatologist about this smallish, irregular, almost birthmark-looking spot. And I assured her I had. She pressed me and said, when?
他认为是一个玫瑰纹身的东西。它在我的右上臂二头肌上。那天我一反常态地穿着一件无袖连衣裙。这位后来我称之为安吉拉（Angela）的女士——虽然我真的不知道这是否是她自我介绍时的名字，还是我后来给她的名字——但她问我是否就这个偏小、不规则、几乎像胎记的斑点看过皮肤科医生。我向她保证我看过。她追问并问我，什么时候？
And I had to stop to think and I counted back the months and I know years. It had been over three years. I was supposed to follow up a year after, but I was so caught up in my job I never did. The dermatologist's office never reached out to me, either so blah, blah, blah time moves on. So this woman urged me to call my doctor Monday morning first thing.
我不得不停下来思考，我倒数着月份，我知道还有年份。那已经过去三年多了。我本该在一年后复查，但我太忙于工作而从未去过。皮肤科医生的诊所也从未联系过我，所以巴拉巴拉，时间就这样流逝了。因此，这位女士敦促我在星期一早上第一件事就打电话给我的医生。
Please don't wait," she said. She explained she was a nurse for a plastic surgeon, and as she gently touched my arm, she said, really, don't wait. And thanks to her, I didn't wait. In the following weeks of Drs. appointments, biopsies, and then the surgery are all a bit of a blur, but because everything moved very fast.
“请不要等待，”她说。她解释说她是一名整形外科医生的护士，当她温柔地触碰我的手臂时，她说，真的，不要等待。多亏了她，我没有等待。随后的几周里，医生的预约、活检以及接下来的手术都有点模糊，因为一切进展得太快了。
But my melanoma was removed, and my six inch ragged scar that travels almost from the top of my shoulders down my arm is my everyday reminder of her, Angela, my guardian angel. She saved my life. Melanoma is a cancer that metastasizes faster than any other except pancreatic and if I hadn't listened to her, I probably wouldn't be here. So to my hero, Nurse Angela, thank you for my life. Jackie Briggs of Portland, Oregon. She tells us that about two years after that conference and her melanoma surgery, she quit
但我的黑色素瘤被切除了，那个从我肩膀顶部一直延伸到手臂几乎有一英寸长的参差不齐的伤疤，是我每天对她的提醒——安吉拉，我的守护天使。她救了我的命。黑色素瘤是一种转移速度比除了胰腺癌之外任何其他癌症都快的癌症，如果我没有听她的，我可能就不会站在这里了。所以献给我的英雄，安吉拉护士，谢谢你赐予我生命。来自俄勒冈州波特兰的杰基·布里格斯。她告诉我们，在那次会议和黑色素瘤手术大约两年后，她辞去了
that 60-hour-a-week IT job. She also took up mountain climbing and submitted 12 peaks. When we spoke with her, she was happily retired, going kayaking, hiking, and motorcycle riding whenever possible. We have an unsung hero of our own to share today, Laura Correll, who is our lead producer on this project. Over the past few months, Laura has taken on my Unsung Hero with great skill and conscientiousness. This project could not have succeeded without her writing and sound design talents.
那份每周工作60小时的IT工作。她还开始登山并登顶了12座山峰。当我们与她交谈时，她已经愉快地退休了，只要有可能就会去划皮划艇、徒步旅行和骑摩托车。今天我们也有自己的无名英雄要分享，劳拉·科雷尔（Laura Correll），她是这个项目的首席制片人。在过去的几个月里，劳拉以极高的技巧和认真态度接手了《我心中的无名英雄》。没有她的写作和声音设计才华，这个项目不可能成功。
Thank you, Laura. To share your Unsung Hero with us, go to myunsunghero.org for instructions on how to record and send us your story. Again, that website is myansanghero.org. If you liked today's episode, please be sure to share it with a few friends. What if my recommendations really make all the difference? I'm Shankar Vedantam. See you soon. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
谢谢你，劳拉。要与我们分享您的无名英雄，请访问 myunsunghero.org 获取有关如何录制并发送您的故事的说明。再次说明，网址是 myunsunghero.org。如果您喜欢今天的节目，请务必与几位朋友分享。如果我的推荐真的发挥了所有作用呢？我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。再见。本集尚无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。